non je prends mon soir vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du Nouvel
Observateur producteur à France Inter et
vous avez déjà publié de nombreux essais
et vous êtes ici aujourd'hui pour la
publication de votre premier roman on va
en parler mais avant j'aimerais qu'on
dise un mot de la faire Thierry maison
Thierry messanc et ce garçon que j'ai
reçu dans cette émission qui a écrit un
livre qui met en doute la version du FBI
et de la CIA sur les événements du 11
septembre à New York et à Washington
dans le dernier numéro du Nouvel
Observateur thierry messanc est qualifié
de négationnistes par votre
correspondant aux États-Unis qui
s'appelle Philippe boulet gercour alors
je peux vous apprendre ce que vous dire
négationniste ou négateur ce sont les
gens qui ni la réalité des chambres à
gaz durant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
exemple Robert Faurisson florisson est
un négationniste alors il aurait mieux
va lui dire révisionniste parce que
réviser l'histoire même s'il a un peu
tôt pour réviser celle là réviser
l'histoire ça existe c'est un truc mais
le la méthode d'à peu près la même si
vous voulez c'est à dire qu'on prend un
certain nombre de détails qui paraissent
troublant les contradictions et puis on
bâtit une théorie alternative parce que
il dit moi je n'affirmerie rien je mets
en doute la version officielle mais
c'est pas vrai du tout moi j'ai lu le
livre moi aussi le livre d'abord
il y a le titre c'est pas un doute c'est
pas on dit pas c'est pas sûr il y a des
contradictions on dit l'effroyables
imposture les froyens postures c'est une
un titre un peu péremptoire et en
dessous il y a marqué l'avion il y a
jamais d'avion sur le Pentagone c'est
pas y a-t-il eu un avion ou peut-être
qu'il y a pas il y a pas eu d'avion donc
c'est une c'est une une affirmation il a
une thèse contraire à celle de de la
thèse ou de tout le monde si vous voulez
c'est pas pour ça qu'il a tort c'est il
n'y a pas de complot Kennedy il y a eu
un complot oui c'est aujourd'hui oui
donc à l'époque les gens qui disaient
que Kennedy n'avaient pas été
[Musique]
traité peut-être pas de négationniste à
l'époque non non il y avait un procureur
qui s'appelle monsieur garrixon quelque
part un type d'Internet c'était un
procureur de des États-Unis qui mettait
en doute la version officielle là on
n'est pas du tout dans cette hypothèse
les le bouquin de naissance il est fait
à partir de la synthèse au fond des des
informations ou des affirmations qui
sont sur internet depuis des semaines
alors le sentiment que j'ai c'est qu'on
est en train d'essayer de diaboliser ce
Thierry Messan et quelques années aux
expliquer que tirer Messein était un
titre formidable il avait le Réseau
Voltaire humilité pour la cause
homosexuelle il était au parti
c'est pas n'importe qui c'est pas
Emmanuel Ratier non plus Thierry messanc
moi je l'ai reçu le premier ici ça m'a
été énormément reproché comme vous le
savez tous après moi
avoir pris assez de précautions à toi
simplement après moi
c'est il a reçu France 5 il a reçu canal
l'a reçu Europe 1 l'a reçu donc
finalement c'est quelqu'un qui a été
reçu par toutes les chaînes de
télévision et de radio après être venu
ici je comprends pas ces diabolisation a
priori c'est-à-dire qu'on exclut tout
c'est pas a priori excusez-moi le livre
et c'est moi j'ai demandé dès que j'ai
été mis au courant de ça j'ai vu le
bouquin et j'ai appelé le correspondant
aux États-Unis il correspondance aux
États-Unis n'est pas un agent de la CIA
vous savez
et si ils disent qu'il dit c'est qu'il a
vérifié là-dessus je suis je dois dire
d'accord avec Laurent Geoffrin et parce
que avant d'abord les choses se font un
peu serrer et non a priori et d'autre
part avant d'être un livre cette idée là
était une rumeur sur internet alors je
dirais tout de suite un mot sur internet
mais je crois qu'il y a un grand danger
à laisser entrer comme ça brutalement la
rumeur dans la sphère publique ou non du
débat pour enrichir le débat
démocratique parce que le débat c'est
quoi c'est plusieurs perspectives sur un
même monde sur un même fait sur un même
événement mais une fois que la
distinction entre le fait et l'opinion
est en quelque sorte suspendu oublier
alors il y a plus de débats le débat
meurt il y a plus que des somnambules
des gens qui arrivent chacun avec leur
fait leur version et qui se croient et
on ne peut plus parler et je crois que
ça avoir avec Internet justement le net
c'est une belle utopie et toutes les
utopies dès qu'elle se réalise donne des
enfers des enfers très convenables c'est
l'utopie effectivement de l'égalité et
de la liberté des discours si à l'époque
si à l'époque de l'assassinat de Kennedy
à l'époque du suicide de Marilyn Monroe
c'est l'époque où on nous expliquait que
François Mitterrand n'avait jamais eu la
francise que de la part du Maréchal
Pétain si à l'époque de Mazarine tout ça
la presse a mis du temps à en parler
c'est l'époque il y a eu internet ça va
peut-être précipiter les choses
accélérer les choses
tous les discours sont déco tous les
discours sont libres donc il y a plus
rien il y a plus il y a plus de il y a
plus de censure il y a plus de
différence ça vous inquiète ce qui est
plus de parce que c'est terrible sont
les médias globalement quand il vous
présente une information il vous
explique en même temps ce qu'il faut en
penser dans ce cas-là de vous inquiéter
c'est que une personne c'est la même
chose il y a plus personne pour vous
expliquer ce qu'il faut en prendre
par exemple que Ben Laden est un agent
de la CIA il a été non justement non
c'est comme si on disait de Gaulle
c'était l'agent de Churchill non c'était
l'Allier et Ben Laden effectivement à
une période fixe bien délimitée a été
favorisée par les Américains parce qu'il
voulait battre les Russes mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'on est un agent ça c'est la
vision du complot on va aller plus loin
on va oublier on va oublier mais sans
puisque on va passer
d'abord il est pas là pour se défendre
ensuite on va passer à Michel Peyrard
qui était sur splato la semaine dernière
Michel Perrin est grand reporter à Paris
Match il a dit ici il a dit ici il a dit
qu'en Ben Laden a quitté djalabad il a
quitté déjà là-bas avec 150 voitures
c'est pas le Molla Omar qui s'en va sur
une moto là 150 voitures donc à ce
moment là il y a des satellites
américains qui voient à partir Ben Laden
et son escort avec 150 voitures dans le
désert afghan donc Peyrard dit ça
j'ai appelé les journaux et je leur ai
dit est-ce que vous allez enquêter parce
que Michel Perrin c'est pas Thierry
messanc alors j'ai appelé le Journal du
Dimanche non on va pas enquêter très
bien libération en enquête pas le monde
Schneider man me dit moi de toute façon
mon problème c'est pas d'enquêté voir ça
avec pleinel et cetera donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il y a un truc qui
est dit dans une émission de télévision
devant 2 millions et demi 3 millions de
gens un samedi soir et le lundi matin la
presse n'en parle pas est-ce que c'est
un fonctionnement normal je vous pose la
question puisque vous êtes non seulement
le patron de l'homme
on a enquêté immédiatement
est-ce que vous allez enquêter sur ce
qui a déclaré mais si vous me le
demandez je le ferai je vous le demande
parce que si vous voulez je trouve c'est
quand même non mais c'est quand même
sérieusement et sérieusement j'ai rien à
vous demander vous savez bien mais je
trouve quand même que c'est un peu grave
comme ça des choses qui sont dites et
qu'ils ont complètement ignoré ce que je
racontais la semaine dernière c'est
quand moi je disais que Mitterrand avait
Francis comme traité de blasphémateur et
puis un jour Gilles Martinet le disait
dès 1965 non c'est vrai que ça a été euh
secret de polichinelle
un secret de polichinelle ça veut dire
l'information à deux vitesses d'un côté
il y a les journalistes qui savent des
trucs ils en parlent entre dans les
dîners tu sais Mitterrand et une fille
qui elle s'appelle Mazarine elle habite
Berlio mais sur le dit pas et puis check
Mitterrand a eu la France risque mais ça
on le dit pas on le dit pas au bon
peuple qui achète nos journaux on se dit
entre nous dans les dîners donc
qu'est-ce que l'internet c'est pas la
fin finalement de cette information à
deux vitesses
c'est de l'artisanat il faut qu'elle
soit vérifiée enfin la France aussi
c'était franchement il suffit de
regarder
il y a des journaux il y a des journaux
qui l'ont dit d'abord beaucoup il y a
minute qui l'a dit et à l'époque quand
vous disiez Mitterrand c'est pas des
ragots qui sont en minute minute était
le Thierry Messan de l'époque on
pourrait dire qu'est-ce qui va se passer
le jour le jour où il y a un truc qui va
sortir on va s'apercevoir que dans la
belle histoire parce que vous dites mais
ils vend une histoire tout emballé toute
faite comme ça qui est du prêt à acheter
le jour on va s'apercevoir que dans la
version de la CIA et du FBI il y a un
truc qui cloche qu'est-ce qui va se
passer mais il y a peut-être des choses
qui clochent déjà il y a effectivement
il y a des contradictions il y a des
bizarrer les journaux qui ont parlé de
ça on dit les autorités n'ont pas tout
dit donc il y a des questions qui
restent posées évidemment bien sûr mais
il s'en suit pas qu'il y a eu un complot
de 3000 personnes pour faire croire
qu'il y a pas eu d'avion c'est quand
même
un certain nombre de problèmes des des
interrogations vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus puisque vous l'avez lu il y a
un certain nombre d'interrogations qui
sont soulevées et il est traités
à la conclusion et qui nie l'existence
même de la ville c'est grave d'appeler
quelqu'un
d'accord
moi je crois que cette histoire enfin
parler encore des sentiments puisque je
ne suis pas aussi érudit que vous mais
et le sentiment que j'ai moi en tout cas
c'est que ce terrorisme c'est pour dire
quelque chose d'insupportable pour eux
parce que il vient pas comme ça je pense
pas qu'il y a eu des traditions de
terrorisme dans ces pays-là
depuis des siècles je crois que les ils
ont envie de dire aussi qu'ils en ont
marre de traiter comme les derniers
parce que le racisme existe en Occident
depuis bien longtemps et si on est allé
coloniser du pays c'est aussi parce
qu'on se croyait supérieur à eux et
j'ose le dire parce que sinon j'aimerais
faire attaquer moi j'ai pas de bon moi
je vous assure j'ai le disque de
Marianne un petit appareil photo et puis
je veux dire il faut il faut faire il
faut voir un petit peu des deux côtés je
comprends votre passion vous avez des
choses à dire mais aussi il faut essayer
peut-être un petit peu de voir de
l'autre côté quoi
[Applaudissements]
un tout petit mot
voir de l'autre côté c'est entendre
aussi ce qu'il dit et de l'autre côté
c'est un côté qui dit le dji hard contre
la civilisation des juifs et des Croisés
alors moi je pense que la moindre des
choses justement quand on est du cœur
c'est de prendre son ennemi au
sérieux et de ne pas là ce serait un
égarement de la mauvaise conscience que
de dire qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mal
moi représentant de cette civilisation
géographique pour mériter ça rien ma
réponse c'est rien rien responsable
terrorisme n'a pas que des causes dans
la folie des hommes le terrorisme des
causes sociales le diable le diable les
folies les inégalités sociales
favorisent la propagande de terrorisme
un jour j'avais une discussion avec un
philosophe sur Carlos et Carlos venait
d'être arrêtés et il disait il disait le
terrorisme c'est l'arme des désespéré
Carlo c'est un fils de bourgeois
extrêmement riche donc ça tombait mal
avec Ben Laden ça tombe encore plus mal
avec Mohamed ATA aussi donc il faut
aussi prendre en considération
mais on peut s'en préoccuper autrement
vous croyez pas la fin ne justifie pas
les moyens et des moyens inadmissibles
provoque des fins elle-même
inadmissibles ça on peut peut-être
s'entendre là-dessus c'est assez minimal
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu